Autorama needle yeah i love how quick it
is actually how i could you straight
away that happens all right there we go
back this way we need to get the thingie
for scary voice man what is I don't have
any grenades but I just want to know the
button is grenades that one okay so
maybe if we I do ok I was wondering what
they were a little circles off the top
and I was like I'm a plasma grenades I
don't know because I would've thought
that was a different button apparently
it's not
oh it's the best come on come on
and that's how we deal with that always
loved the need look these guys man
stress me out give me a break thank you
explosions I'll go first
you did not dead yeah you did yeah you
did the gun transponders the signals are
originating somewhere below your
position well let's go there then
you know like evacuated at the last
minute I missed should kill whoever has
that needle so I can get me a moes give
me that thanks friend oh and I get it
why did I speak the ammo up Wendigo he
had one I have no Emma she's not a good
time ah stop it with the charging just
wish me up stop I can't handle it stop
it you're so annoying No holy crap that
is so stressful my energy shields will
be fine don't be silly I got this I'm
the master chief oh my god yes people
jewel wheels
ha take that there's another lived in
the next home oh hey sea dog okay is
that really necessary I could have just
walked through right right it you know
checks I thought I stuck it on a hood
like I'm set and then I had to just done
that sucks next time are you go buddy
what's that oh no oh well I didn't fall
to my death it's okay i just fell how do
i get back up it's true y'all been I
just did Thank You matter they all go is
it it's not 100 okay I wasn't expecting
that oh my god what's happening holy
crap there are two verbs are more even
if the tension vlog Oh tripping out okay
like the Doctor Who theme song said it
should have just played that
no no stop doing that I do not like it
stop it no you got damn it oh are you
serious let's give the nod to go all
right good why is that guy wait they're
not
nope nope nope nope I don't take kindly
to stop doing it stop it I'll beat you
up for pheasants yes and put that that
military training to good use their
that's what's up okay give me your need
look
died all of you stop taking cover get
worse eh I
it's we doubt that good god damn i
Madame Mao again if i go to the old 1i
can actually see way better it's like
everything's just kind of Elijah or I
supposed yes excellent haha alright
where are we going that's right we are
continuing to go this way I'm just going
to check wine go tonic you don't way to
go please I'm in need of your assistance
what am i doing
this is what you're supposed to help out
tell me what to do what you're not what
are you even good for
huh okay then walkie you can do this
finally oh my god this one this looks
fun
level I did I just did that careful of
the guard listen no no that sends me up
Oh want to go down all right nice little
lift
what are we doing here
but Valda go down I think I go down
there
but how do I get down there
true yo
but these things
oh not you again I hate you so much oh
yeah okay wasn't so bad hey
stop backing out man there we go got you
that time jack oh oh oh oh hey hey
friend listen up Marines she's hunting a
prophet and you're gonna tell you all
one more group of Marines to go to you
what get your ass back down okay where
are the other ones same level somewhere
surely
maybe where these guys gone morguard the
middle level
she said
puncture do you okay let's find the
place where I have to go back up LOL did
you guys get here where did you just
come from and that she doesn't make
sense what Xiao was easy okay up we go
dude so damn tough
okay wait to let me try to Snoopy long
jump back on up oh yes suck on that hey
lady
nice
thank you should be oh good here good
work no worries I don't call me the
master chief or nothing